Speaker 1: Hey, David, could fighting vote
by mail in twenty twenty backfire horribly
for Republicans?
I think it could.
You know, I went back and looked at some of
the history of this.
In the late 80s, Republicans started working
to expand the appeal of vote by mail because
Republicans looked at the demographics and
they realized we skew older and we may do
disproportionately better if we make it easier
to vote.
And voting by mail would make it easier to
vote, particularly to older folks who may
no longer be driving or may have limited mobility
or for whatever other reason, maybe would
be more likely to vote if it's easier for
them.
And they started to work on a plan to expand
vote by mail and to make sure that their electorate
knew that that was going on.
Those are the same.
I mean, they're not literally the same people,
but that's the same Republican Party that
even in twenty eighteen was still looking
at.
Oh, let's put let's require a mail in a mail
ballot box at every early voting site in the
state.
They were doing that in twenty eighteen income's
Donald Trump.
We have the pandemic and it really starts
to seem that more vote by mail is going to
be bad for Donald Trump.
So in 2020, the Republican Party does a 180
that a lot of people don't even know is a
180 and starts opposing vote by mail.
It'll lead to fraud.
It'll lead to, you know, all these different
things that didn't happen.
And it turned out that if it helped in twenty
twenty, it didn't help enough in the sense
that Republicans still lost the Senate and
Republicans still lost the White House.
But now there is concern among some Republicans,
including in Florida, that it's a runaway
freight train that can't be stopped, the momentum
of stopping mail and voting and indeed, dozens
of the hundreds of bills that we've seen put
forward by Republicans since the November
election and since Biden's inauguration would
further limit early voting, vote by mail,
et cetera, strengthen voter ID laws to make
it more difficult to vote all of that stuff.
The Washington Post spoke to a Florida state
Republican Party official who said.
We are worried about this, and so while publicly
they feel the pressure to at least say they're
in favor of all the stuff Republicans are
doing, Florida Republicans know that particularly
with elderly and military voters, which what
groups do they have left?
Even the military, where both elderly and
military went more for Biden in twenty twenty
than they typically do for Democrats.
But these are two of the strongest Republican
voting groups.
Some Republicans in Florida are privately
saying, can we publicly push this stuff, but
then privately try to exempt older people
and military to make it really easy for them
to keep voting by mail or voting early or
whatever the case may be.
So the answer to the question, could opposing
vote by mail and early voting backfire on
Republicans?
It absolutely could.
What will they now do publicly to try to figure
out a way to thread that needle?
I don't know.
And I don't really care if it does end up
backfiring on them.
It's they have to.
What's the USA let you made the bed now sleep
in it or something like that.
Eat the oats.
You so I don't even know.
I'm looking for proverbs and similes and analogies
here and failing.
But this is a problem of their own making
and now they're going to have to deal with
it